[Music]
in an old house an old woman gathers her
knitting supplies
this is a special project for a little
boy named tommy she loves dearly she
knits furiously and soon the mix of
cotton synthetic fiber and cloth of
every color turn from raw materials into
something else a teddy bear she puts the
finishing touches on the bear this is a
very special bear after all and sends
the patchwork bear off to its
destination with a red get well card the
card is labeled k rose the bear and
inside she writes a personal note to
tommy because only time can mend all
wounds love grammy but this package of
love would never reach its destination
scp-2295 was found at the site of a
crashed mail truck and it looks exactly
like a standard handmade teddy bear with
one difference on the left side of its
chest just under its jaunty tan bow it
wears a heart-shaped pin but not a
standard cartoon heart this is a
disturbingly realistic anatomically
correct pin of a heart organ and that's
because
scp-2295 has a specific purpose and it's
one that has everything to do with
actual human organs
scp-2295 spends most of its time
completely inert spending its days as
just another cuddly stuffed toy tests
performed on the toy revealed that it
had no unusual properties and seems to
be a normal handmade keepsake that is
until someone is injured in its presence
not any injury will do a paper cut or
even a broken arm for example won't do
much to activate its anomalous
properties but if it detects a critical
injury to a human organ nearby it will
trigger a secret power one that the
foundation is still trying to figure out
how it works because
scp-2295 is a miracle worker when it
senses the presence of someone with a
serious injury to an organ and is within
two meters of them scp-2295
springs into action suddenly from
unknown sources the bear will produce
objects including scissors white thread
and sewing needles or a crocheting hook
from its mouth if there are any crafting
supplies on hand it will incorporate
those as well and then it gets to work
despite only having hands made of fabric
and stuffing with no fingers the
anomalous bearer is still able to craft
what will end up being a patchwork
recreation of the damaged human's organ
cute if a little creepy but that's just
the beginning the injured person
mysteriously falls unconscious and the
patchwork organ which the foundation has
designated as
scp-2295-1 instance will disappear the
scp-2295-1
instance will then physically replace
the damaged organ inside the person's
body it's unknown how this happens the
patchwork organ will simply appear
inside of their body taking the place of
the original lung or kidney or whichever
organ was failing it's unknown where the
original organ goes to since it seems to
just disappear as soon as the
2295-1 instance takes its place
surprisingly having this new
cotton-stuffed heart or liver does not
seem to cause any harm and in fact it
works exactly like the real thing there
are never any of the usual issues that
come with a transplant like the risk of
it being rejected by the body as the
organic tissue seems to have no issue
connecting with the organ and treating
it like it was there all along in all
instances of scp-2290
performing this adorable but rudimentary
surgery the subjects have made a full
and complete recovery
scp-2295 might sound like a miracle
worker but that isn't to say that its
abilities aren't without their own set
of complications when faced with two
injured subjects scp-2295
seems to always gravitate towards fixing
the younger subject up first maybe owing
to its creation by a grandmother who
wanted to heal whatever was ailing her
grandson no one knows who tommy was or
exactly what disease or injury he was
recovering from but his grandmother
clearly felt it was serious enough to
create this special bear for him while
scp-2295 will heal anyone it seems to be
primarily a guardian for the young and
it takes its duties very seriously even
to the point of self-sacrifice while
scp-2295 is able to pull some of its
supplies out of thin air it still always
needs some raw materials to craft the
new organ including fabric and stuffing
and if there are none available
scp-2295 will obtain them the hard way
the patchwork bear will sacrifice its
own body tearing itself open and
removing any fabric or stuffing it needs
without any concern for its own
well-being in order to craft a new organ
for its patient it slowly regenerates
its own stuffing at the rate of around a
gram of stuffing per day but it needs to
harvest fabric to repair its outer layer
which the foundation happily makes
available to it offering it a variety of
patterns and types it's no surprise that
a teddy bear capable of healing mortal
wounds would be of great interest to the
scp foundation and as soon as it was
recovered from the crash mail truck they
immediately began tests to find out more
about it could it heal literally any
organ were there any limits to its
abilities there was only one way to find
out and the foundation had the perfect
test subjects d-class personnel whose
interactions with non-cuddly teddy bear
scps frequently left them with critical
external and internal injuries the first
test subject brought in
d2353 a 38 year old man who was in poor
health not due to his work as a d-class
personnel but from his years and years
of heavy smoking his lungs were
seriously damaged which gave him trouble
breathing and made any serious physical
exertion extremely difficult he wasn't
critically injured or in danger of dying
immediately but that didn't matter to
scp-2295
d2353 quickly passed out and the bear
sprang into action he proceeded to take
two textile swatches one black and one
red and create a pair of fabric lungs
which it installed in the patient when
he awoke d 2353 found he had full
healthy lung function again as if he
never picked up his deadly habit but now
the foundation researchers needed to
know how
scp-2295 would do with even more
complicated ailments
d3542 was 50 years old and his heart was
not in good shape not only did he have a
serious case of atherosclerosis which is
a disease where cholesterol plaque
builds up and blocks blood flow and can
put you at serious risk of a heart
attack but he also had an irregular
heartbeat this d-class was in bad shape
but that was no problem for scp-2295
who took a collection of different
colors of yarn in a crochet hook and
created a plushy heart just like the
lungs had acted as if they were
completely regular organs after the
heart anomalously ended up inside the
man's chest it began to beat normally
and performed all the complicated
functions of a human heart but there was
one detail that shocked the onlooking
doctors before the yarn organ had
vanished the doctors had seen that it
was beating so is there any organ that
scp-2295 can't replace that was about to
be tested when
d7894 was brought in a 24 year old woman
she had suffered serious burns all over
her torso left abdomen and right leg she
was brought in and sedated to numb the
agonizing pain
and researchers were worried that they
had come up against the limit of
scp-2295's abilities since the skin is
the largest organ after all but
scp-2295 wasn't phased at all the bear
immediately started sewing segments of
patchwork fabric and layering them onto
the damaged skin replacing the dermis
and epidermis layer by layer unlike the
other cases these replacement organs are
visible and d7895 now has patchwork skin
just like her talented surgeon and
amazingly the fabric has the same sense
of touch that her regular skin did the
final test of
scp-2295's abilities came with d2723
who was only 18 years old this last
minute d-class test was performed
because he was showing signs of severe
cerebral hemorrhage the kind that would
cause brain damage in only minutes and
would be followed soon after by complete
brain death
scp-2295 sprung to life but as soon as
it examined the test subject it became
distressed it started frantically
grasping at random material around it as
if it didn't know what to do with them
then it reached inside itself and
provided a large chocolate bar which it
offered to the subject sadly to no
effect it then seemed to admit defeat as
it grabbed tightly onto the subject's
leg observers reported that it was
leaking a tear-like solution from its
small knitted eyes as it embraced the
dying d-class in his final moments sadly
it seems that the human brain is the one
mystery that even scp-2295
can't solve
scp-2295 appears to pose no threat to
anyone and was classified as safe after
testing it is inactive when not in the
presence of an injured person and has
never displayed hostile instincts when
active the foundation determined that it
should be stored in a standard
containment locker in site-37 where it
can be kept safely until it's needed for
tests or to repair an injured scp
personnel access is limited to those
with level 3 or higher security
clearance and any contact with the bear
is highly regulated but there is one
element of
scp-2295's existence that continues to
worry foundation staff
scp-2295's full origins and the
grandmother who crafted it are unknown
the note it was found with is the only
clue as to where it may have come from
but there are plenty within the
foundation who are suspicious of the
veracity of this letter and they have
good reason not to be too trusting
because another bear with similar
abilities exists and it is distinctly
less benevolent than scp-2295
scp-1048 is also a teddy bear but it is
capable of moving on its own and
communicating through gestures at all
times it was initially allowed to wander
around independently and seemed to make
its home at site-24 a happier place but
then it began to display its own
crafting abilities
scp-1048 is able to craft duplicates of
itself and while the original was
seemingly harmless the ones it made were
not
these similarly shaped bears were made
of disturbing materials and were
extremely hostile towards any humans
they encountered the first scp-1048-a
was made entirely out of human ears and
when it shrieked it caused anyone nearby
to generate ear-like growths all over
their bodies eventually causing them to
suffocate the creature disappeared and
an on-site researcher was found to be
missing an ear the creations of scp-1048
only got stranger and deadlier from
there scp-1048-b
was found in the site's cafeteria where
it was moving around in a halted jerky
fashion it then started bursting at the
seams and revealed what appeared to be a
human fetus inside when the creature
screamed it sounded like a much louder
version of a human infant and its crows
caused massive internal damage to anyone
around it
scp-1048-b was killed in the ensuing
conflict with foundation agents ending
its threat but scp-1048 was learning
deadlier techniques when
scp-1048-c was discovered it looked to
be a teddy bear made entirely out of
rusty scrap metal when it was spotted by
dr carver and targeted by foundation
personnel the creature turned violent
and proved to have incredible strength
jumping through the agents who were
trying to neutralize it tearing through
their bodies like tissue paper attempts
to damage it were unsuccessful and both
it and the bear made out of ears are
still on the loose along with the
original
scp-1048 capturing it is major priority
for the foundation because no one wants
to see what it will create next is there
a connection between these two very
different teddy bears no one has been
able to answer this question the origins
of scp-1048 are unknown and so is any
connection to the mysterious grandmother
who may have made k-rose the bear but
their abilities are similar with both
able to craft living objects out of
seemingly any material they just have
very different ideas as to what a good
use of their crafting abilities are it
is fortunate that an anomaly is
potentially powerful as scp-2295
seems to only want one thing to help
those in need especially those who are
the most vulnerable for more on another
apparently harmless object with
mysterious powers watch
scp-066 eric's toy or check out this
scp-explained video instead